[Music]
first time binky no no no long time ago
different life now you come back yes I'm
looking for something you can find
whatever you wish until today I'm at a
man who kidnapped little girl from her
American mother will not be looking for
such a thing will be dangerous for you
men like him with paper Robert I'm the
only friend it's great you helping all
these random people and everything
stay off the radar something happens to
one of ours so I'm obligated to look
into it
about you every time oh I am just like
you're dead
[Music]
yeah what's the matter
[Music]
they knew what floor she was on they're
tying up loose ends
exactly partner seven years max mistake
to go to war with him
[Music]
they're going to war with me
whoever did this of all chart skill sets
[Music]
here at the agency family does he start
right very good
well not one one goat
they killed my friends
so I'm gonna kill each and every one of
them and then when they disappoint me is
that I only get to do it once
[Music]
senior care and all those books around I
figured you for some kind of teacher
from a high level pay for an assassin
[Music]
you